[Musique]
la famille presque zéro déchet alors
celle-ci je l'aime beaucoup parce que
justement elle a la particularité d'être
voyez dans ce message de tolérance c'est
un objectif il faut pas se dire si j'y
arrive pas c'est foutu en fait c'est un
fin après l'autre qu'on apprend à
marcher là vous avez un plateau donc
c'est un très chouette jeu on rigole
beaucoup avec la famille et en même
temps on apprend plein de choses parce
que finalement il y a des cartes à
l'intérieur avec de la sensibilisation à
plein de gestes qu'on peut ensuite
appliquer au quotidien tout est à
construire soi-même c'est mis déplié
dans la boîte et c'est tout en carton
voilà la petite tasse c'est moi qui l'ai
rajouté mais sinon elle n'y est pas dans
le jeu et puis vous voyez on a un gros
tas de cartes plein de défis les
cotonpad donc démaquillant je mets mon
démaquillant dessus et je me démaquille
ou je me nettoie le visage ils sont
réutilisables donc au lieu de jeter à
chaque
nettoyage de la peau je le mets dans mon
linge sale et au bout d'un et puis bah
toutes les semaines je fais mes lessives
quoi et puis ici c'est la petite
pochette pour le savon donc c'est une
pochette que j'ai acheté sur un stand
zéro déchet sur un marché de Noël
ou un marché artisanal elle a un tissu
imperméable à l'intérieur un bouton
pression un joli tissu à l'extérieur et
ça me permet quand je pars en voyage de
mettre mon savon ou mon shampoing solide
dans ma pochette
et voilà
comme ça ça reste propre dans ma trousse
de toilette